I think three is a good number okay I
think three you know why three so I read
a story about Billy Graham one time
which was great he says look he says
there was an error where these pastors
were traveling on their own and they're
going and giving talks and these young
girls will be like oh my God that Pastor
is such a great speaker and it would go
to Pastor's room and Pastor would sin
right after you just gave a great
message so Pastor said moving forward
we're only going to travel with twos
we're not going to go with uh one we'll
room up with two of us together so these
pastors going what they notice is if one
Pastor can sell the other one on doing
something and not telling anybody they
can generally do something bad then they
said no we have to travel in three
because in three at least one person's
gonna say guys I'm not in it so one is
going to make the other one from not
doing anything dumb so if you have three
kids say two of the kids convincing each
other to do some stupid one other kid's
gonna say guys I don't want to do that
because that's gonna happen and then if
there's four there's two people that can
agree on this and there's two people
like and then you have good debate so
that's a good show